In May 1960, the Soviets shot down a U-2 spy
plane over Soviet airspace.
U-2s could fly at 70,000 feet (21.3km) but
apparently, that wasn’t high enough.
We needed to go higher.
To space!
So, the US needed a satellite that could take
pictures!
The thing is, a U-2 flight eventually lands…
The film in the cameras could be taken out
and developed.
If we launch a satellite, we needed a way
to get the film from space to intelligence
officers.
This had never been done before.
They worked for years but eventually the CIA
launched the US’s first spy satellite, CORONA.
CORONA’s first on-board camera was five
feet (1.2M) long, and could see things about
40 feet (12M) across.
Like a building…
It was America’s first imaging satellite,
and also the first US satellite program, ever.
Since it used film, CORONA would take pictures,
and drop the film in heavy buckets with parachutes.
The buckets would reenter the atmosphere,
and be caught by a “claw hook” hanging
off military cargo planes, or recovered by
ships after splashdown.
Assuming they didn’t sink (which happened).
This was the first time humans had recovered
anything sent to space.
And though crazy, it became hugely successful.
Pictures were taken of Soviet or Chinese missile
sites, which helped the US monitor and negotiate
Cold War treaties.
The first CORONA model Keyhole-1 only lasted
a day, but it gave way to lots more models.
Kodak made lighter film, engineers designed
better cameras and capsules...Eventually,
the engineers achieved 2 feet (61 cm) of resolution!
You could see people standing around military
bases all over the world.
Over the twelve years of the project, the
US launched over 120 Keyhole satellites, and
took over 800,000 images We know all this,
because it was declassified in the 1990s.
President Clinton and Vice President Gore
released the images to the public to help
environmental efforts -- because these were
the oldest satellite maps of our planet!
Today, you can just go online and spy on a
zoo in North Korea.
You can look at strategic missile site ‘F’
on the border of Nebraska and Wyoming...
Which makes you wonder… what can the satellites
that are still classified see?
For more epic stories of innovation that shaped
our future, check out TheAgeOfAerospace.com
If you enjoyed this video, please subscribe
to our channel.
Imaging our planet changed how we do a lot of things, but on my
new Facebook show, How Close Are We, we're talking about taking pictures of the black hole
at the center of our galaxy. How close are we to seeing it? Find out on Facebook.
The link is in the description
Thanks for watching everyone!